digamos que nuestra función en este caso
es f x igual al logaritmo natural de x y
en este caso lo que vamos a querer es
calcular la pendiente de la recta
tangente a la gráfica justo cuando x es
igual a e es decir queremos calcular la
derivada justo en nuestro punto y muy
bien y queremos saber cuánto vale esto
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
calcular la pendiente justo cuando aquí
vale subimos a la gráfica vemos cómo se
comporta la la recta tangente y ver cuál
es su pendiente entonces vamos a hacer
vamos a utilizar la forma digamos o la
definición formal de lo que es la
derivada y después vamos a utilizar en
este caso la definición alterna para la
formal vamos a tomarnos digamos un x
cualquiera por aquí no sé el que sea muy
bien entonces nos vamos directo a la
gráfica y aquí tengo el punto x coma
f x muy bien donde f
es el logaritmo natural ahora vámonos
con qué pasa si tenemos un x + h
digamos que aquí tenemos x + h entonces
nos vamos directo a la gráfica también y
tenemos aquí el punto x + h coma efe de
x + h muy bien ahí tenemos este punto y
si nosotros queremos calcular la
pendiente de la recta que conecta estos
dos puntos entonces estamos pensando en
una recta secante muy bien
y bueno vamos a calcular esa pendiente
ok entonces para calcularlo vemos el
cambio en la componente vertical que en
este caso sería efe de x + h menos
de equis y todo esto va dividido entre
el cambio en la componente horizontal
que sería x + h menos x que si nos damos
cuenta eso simplemente es h verdad x + h
le restó x pues sólo nos queda h muy
bien ahora el punto el punto central de
todo esto es hacer que esté x + h se
vaya apareciendo cada vez más a x es
decir vayamos moviéndonos hacia la
izquierda en este caso es decir que la h
sea cada vez más chiquita muy bien de
esa forma nosotros podríamos aproximar
muy bien lo que es la pendiente de la
recta tangente justo en el punto x
entonces lo que necesitamos es calcular
el límite voy a ponerlo con color blanco
el límite cuando h tiende a cero de esta
expresión y cuando h se hace cero pues x
+ h se va apareciendo muchísimo a la x
muy bien entonces está justamente es la
definición formal de lo que es la
derivada de la función f en él
x ahora bien a nosotros no nos interesa
en todos los puntos nos interesa
justamente para cuando x es igual a que
el número es ok entonces vamos a
calcularlo tenemos que calcular f prima
en el punto
en cuando x vale y esto es igual a quien
esto es igual por esta definición de
arriba al límite cuando h tiende a cero
de nuestra función f evaluada en x + h
que en este caso es el logaritmo natural
de ahorita pongo que bueno desde y más h
muy bien menos el logaritmo natural de
donde quiero evaluar que en este caso es
que todo esto entre h entonces
sustituimos en vez de x ponemos y aquí
ponemos el e y ya quedó verdad entonces
esto es lo que nos da la pendiente de la
recta tangente en esencialmente esta
expresión de aquí arriba es una función
medio loca de x verdad está medio loca
porque tiene un límite y estamos
evaluando en cosas medio raras pero
bueno esta es la definición de la
derivada como función de x ahora si nos
interesa en el punto en particular que
digamos no nos interesa la derivada en
todos lados sino en un punto muy
particular entonces podemos utilizar la
definición alterna
nos tomamos un equis por aquí digamos
nos tomamos este punto de aquí que es el
x
fx muy bien que de hecho lo voy a poner
de una vez
fx es el logaritmo natural de x este es
ese punto y ahora calculamos la
pendiente de esta recta secante como es
pues es el incremento en la en la
componente llego en la componente
vertical y eso es el logaritmo natural
de x menos
1 que es este punto de aquí todo esto
entre la diferencia en la componente
horizontal que es x menos
x menos e muy bien y ahora lo que yo
quiero es hacer que esta x se aproxime a
él entonces le calculo el límite cuando
x tiende a nuestro número de esta
expresión y esta ésta es justamente la
definición alterna de la derivada pero
en el punto y muy bien entonces puedes
hacerlo con la definición formal que
aquí está que aquí está hecho aunque
esto es aplicando la definición formal o
bien puedes calcular la derivada
utilizando la definición alterna en
cualquiera de los dos casos estamos
haciendo exactamente lo mismo